right so before the break I mentioned
its main lemma and rewriting this now in
slightly different form and now we have
more memory so we can learn so okay so
this is just recall some of these
following definition what do we mean by
a crate and in case you want to but
let's focus now on the main lemma so
recall what we have we had this a
collection of edges each one had this on
subspace or a system of linear equation
and we use it like condition passing for
each of these edges we are like uniform
over these substance now the question is
can we sort of a partition it into few
groups were each s like its own set of
equations that accurately captures the
knowledge and we said that we have this
dichotomy so we look at this w which
will be a random variable taking values
then the values will be affine subspace
of f2 today so this is like if you
condition on reaching here's and you
have some distribution over the edges
and this gives you like a distribution
over subspaces it's a think of this w is
a random variable and now I'm going to
assume that there is no equation that is
shared by most of these by a large
fraction of the subspace so for each
equation for each a B the probability is
that the equation in size 5 by the
subspace okay so the exactly is saying
that every X in the sub so it satisfies
the equation this happens with
probability at most Epsilon so when
whatever the question you are looking at
here it is sure but at most epsilon of
the edges they're still on fractional
then I want to show that the disability
is actually close to the uniform
distribution what is this distribution
so you can think of it as first sampling
W and then something a point in W want
to show that this distribution is close
to the uniform the civilian over all
possible strings the proof would be not
too difficult actually it would be a
simple three analytical proof we have
two proofs so the first proof that
Rongai shows that the distance the
statistical distance between this
distribution is a uniform is at most
Epsilon
okay this parameter x to the n over 2
you seem a little bit big to the n over
2 is pretty big so you need to pick your
epsilon to be smaller than that like to
the minus 0.6 and not for this to work
this would be not good enough for the
sparse case we will need the
strengthening closeness e that most
square root of epsilon times 2 to the K
so if you think of the sparse case case
k is roughly log n so this is much
better than
okay so this is what we will show and
this would be actually a simple quite
simple food so I need to say that in the
sparse case we are not really talking
about the uniform distribution we are
talking about the uniform distribution
over space solution so there is more
difficulty in proving it
I'm not going to these technical issues
[Music]
so think of like condition on this
reaching to this vertex V it gives us
some distribution of all these edges
give you some distribution over
subspaces this but this is general any
any any distribution actually we don't
you don't care how this is any solution
over subspaces
as long as the co dimensions at most K
satisfies this problem
yes so if you you asked for the for the
combination of the distributions whether
there's a inner product that's biased
then if there if any inner product this
bias has to be in at least epsilon bias
has to be in it at least an epsilon
fraction so that so that is one from the
going from epsilon bias - exactly
exactly so what you are what is the
proof Russell already gave the proof of
one so basically the first condition
gives us someone on the Fourier
coefficient of this of this distribution
and this is Bonnie's book is strong
enough to prove this basically it's
called first irani X or them if you know
that you have a distribution and and all
the party functions are very close to
being uniforms and the distribution is
close to me I always think in the
original verse running away
residentially so I just didn't
understand the over to know I think that
this is exactly the luma so I would be
surprised because usually the that the
weights usually stated is that the
expected they expect okay before baby
for a random Xing W yeah right
satisfies at most epsilon so that is
something we forget but but yeah but it
follows from this thing okay so in order
to prove this I want to introduce a
letter already introduced but let's
let's say do it now again so I want to
take a function on the bouillon cube so
it takes strings and gives us some
numbers and I want to represent it in
the Fourier domain so I want to
represent it in function so you can
write it uniquely in this form you start
over all strings are fine 0 1 to the N
you have a coefficient for each string
we call it the Fourier coefficient and
we multiply by this minus 1 to the to
the parity function so minus 1 to the
inner product of alpha and X this
representation is unique if you look at
things different it's it looks like a
multi linear polynomial you can actually
calculate the coefficient by taking the
inner product of your function with the
power T function this expectation under
the uniforms to you
okay so one useful quality is that
basically this party function are not
the orthonormal basis so you get that
the inner product of F 3 feet surfers
expected of F squared equals to the sum
of the squares if the output of the
function was plus minus 1 this equals is
one also but we would not be in this
situation okay so now we were talking
about distribution right so what how do
we associate the function with
distribution we would simply think of
the function the function that takes an
input the stream and outputs the
probability the district is sampled
according to the distribution okay
so in particular like what would be the
function associate with the uniform
distribution will be the constant
function that outputs always 2 to the
minus n
it's what we know you know that it's the
distribution so we know the sum equals
one simple in particular what does this
tell us it tells us that the coefficient
of of the zero vector is to the minus n
all the other three coefficient would be
smaller than that actually so there is
some normalization factor which is
written now let's look at the for a
coefficient of a uniform distribution of
our subspace this is a very simple
distribution in terms of the Fourier
spectrum what do we have this so let's
look at this so we have some subspace
think of it now is a fixed up space and
we look at the vertical fin surface of
the string alpha if the string is
orthogonal to this top substrates
meaning that every equation in the subs
every X in the subspace satisfies this
equation alpha x equals B then we'll
always have like minus 1/2 the beam will
take expectation or this finger so we'll
have so we take expectation began we
have this normalization factor so sorry
so here it would be to deny
and if it is not this is not the case
then we'll have the top of them are ones
and half of them are minus one so they
would cancel each other out and this
would be zero and now I want to look at
what is the Fourier coefficients of D
right so we call what is this D we are
taking expectation of where W and then
taking the uniform distribution over
that which is the same as expectation of
X of X minus 1/2
same as expectation of her W expectation
of UW effects
okay now let's change the order of
summation sorry yeah I already did okay
so this is exactly the coefficient of W
what and what do we know so we know that
for a particular alpha only Epsom
fraction of them as this thing and all
the rest of zero this would be most
absolute value at most epsilon x to the
minus X okay
whenever alpha is orthogonal to W we
would F to the minus and whenever it's
not it would have zero this is I'm not
doing anything
so I could spin again
the first property of you double the
coefficient of a UW will Y Z minus one
to the big thanks to the myosin whenever
everything in X satisfy this equation
then we basically take the expectation
over example the cording to you w minus
1 to a this is the Fourier coefficient
more honest maybe up 2 to the minus n so
it's in the expectation because that's
over the uniform distribution not over
UW but over all right yeah okay fools
fits right but I want to say that you
can also write this with okay sure
maybe something like this maybe okay
maybe the normalization factors that I
get are wrong but something similar to
this so so basically you get here is
that if this equation holds for the
subspace and it's always the same sign
times the normalization factor which
works out if it doesn't then it's zero
why is it sufficient to have given one
expertise we may would expect that if
there is say only one x that does not
satisfy the distributions and I would
get maybe less okay yes zero in the
other case because everything is a
subspace right so if if you're a
subspace then in all of them satisfied
or half of them satisfied oh okay yeah
so meet maybe I should
so now okay so what does it tell us
tells us that we know this bound on all
all for a coefficient of this
distribution and now the two conclusion
will be fairly simple from this
so but irani X or lemma that if you look
at this relation you use the uniform
distribution and you look at the l1
distance between the two okay which is
up to constant the same as statistical
distance and you look at its squared is
nicer to work with this is at most the
sum over the Fourier coefficient square
of me I'm only taking here is a non
empty nonzero coefficients because I
have some normalization factor IV o2 to
the so this is very simple you can try
to do it but on your own it's basically
applying Cauchy Schwarz and then
applying possible so it's really
go from here to this is sometimes called
the Savannah so lemma
and then okay so so now I want to get
one into solar all right so we have
these two bonds so how do I get the
first bound I simply know that each one
of them is more than epsilon squared to
the -2 n ok so then I get this entire
thing is at most coming here to the N
minus 1 alpha right so this is it most
its first time 10 to the N and then I
take the squirrel
and the second case but I'm not gonna do
something to complicate so I'm just
gonna burn the sum of squares by it's
unloading the sum of squares by the
maximal value okay so this is over non
zero so I'm just taking the maximal
coefficient here times the sum of
absolute values
this is the most epsilon times 2 to the
minus
and he claims it because D is a sort of
a convex combination over subspaces each
of codimension K the claim that this is
most two to the K so I nice Tynan to
show this
but let's say that they did then
planning this here would give me let's
all this star give is it star is it most
to the K then I take square root and I
get exactly I just need to show this
this is simple
all right so let's look at this maybe
some here overall our fans
this is most some overall fives
this guy
now I'm changing using linearity of
expectation I'm using the fastest all
these subspaces had Co dimension K so
the number of alphas that get nonzero
coefficient is it most to decay okay so
so each one of them is bounded by two to
the K times 2 to the minus n so this is
the bound I think this actually simplify
what is written in the paper currently
first part we use k equal to n is it
right so in order to make this effective
we sort of needed epsilon to be really
really tiny and then we need K to be
pretty large for this first case the
first thing is not sufficient so this
you wonder incompatibility fingers oh
yeah so right so it's something right so
this could be better exceptionally small
in this deduction
I mean basically we are pounding the
samples first just
okay so so this more or less finishes
the proof of the main lemon from the
main Lama we have the regrouping so
basically we've highlighted how we can
take a branching program convert it into
another and branching program yes yeah
for this first case it's much more
complicated I sort of hide things under
the rug so so this is under the uniform
additions for the general parity
learning problem not for the sparse case
so the sparse case I need to take the
intersection like the uniform
distribution over sparse solution two
equations
the statement of the lemma change in
these days morally no you need for
example that these subspaces would be
sort of pseudo-random and you can
satisfy it by saying that the South
spaces that are actually performed by
seeing the equations and the equations
are random so the substations would have
this property so that's that's
okay so I want to now highlight the
lower bounds on the affine model which
are somewhat simpler and and this also
would reveal a strategy for the general
case how we take it from the parity
learning case to the general learning
mode and problems do not involve parties
I should in the in this conversion
process that you have you're not relying
on the fact that in the I minus one to
layer you have few where he sees you
just relying on the fact that they are
all classified as luckily I think yeah
what is we talk we talk with a mere so
what's surprising about this lemma is
that it's true in the using the first
one you could like set your initial
epsilon to be about to the negative and
it squared or something like that and
then okay like then it would be bad for
the partitioning right almost you said
it's gonna be way too negative a squared
so I would I pick I pick I would pick
epsilon to be two to the men - let's say
a hundred times K and this would give us
miss Sam Bowne
there won't be close in some statistical
distance and then this would tell me
that I have of that either as a fraction
of two thousand - oh okay of the
probability mass the chair an equation
or we are close to the uniform
distribution and then to get to the
subspace I need to sort of like reveal K
equations and this would give me a
fraction which is to the minus order K
raised to the power K because I'm sort
of I will repeat it recursively until I
discover K equations that's why I get
the total mass all your case so you just
pretend that the representation by the
vector space is perfect and over thank
you it's a lot more tricky than how I
presented here yeah it's complicated a
bit to go to actually make it work let's
a naive first like the first attempt
that you will do with some some of that
error would not accumulate additively to
do a more careful analysis this is
perhaps the most trickiest part in the
paper
yes
okay so I wanted to show lower bounds on
this Bank model this branching program I
want to show that in order to be
successful in order to learn K equations
I must be a wide okay so that says a
fixed length so I fixed the number of
samples to the end think of M s that may
be slightly less than an exponential in
it for the general case alright show
that this should be wide eyed look at a
particular vertex V that has like K
equations here
now we will show that the probability of
reaching V
an extremely small visual is its most M
to the K times to the minus K times M
minus 2
so this would be actually a lot smaller
than the inverse of this really think of
these things so it's moving probability
of reaching that particular vertex would
be exponentially small in something like
K times M and as we said in order to
succeed we must reach of such a vertex
so it means that in order to succeed the
number of vertices should be at least
inverse of that this shows that success
means yeah over everything
okay so success means that the number of
nodes here this graph would be at least
to the K
/ n choose K and then the width should
be at least this / M okay so them the
width
okay so so this is the main idea to do
some kind of Union bound to say that for
for each so finger fitters in the
authority case you look at a particular
set of equations let's say n over 10 it
linear equations also says what is the
probability that during the the running
of the AL learning algorithm we would
come up with this set of equations it
will show that this is exponentially
small in n squared this way we can show
so how can we show that
so the nice thing is that now we are
focusing on one vertex so we have a
system of equations and we know that we
want to learn these equations but in
order to learn something we must see
this equation or we must see like linear
combination of equations so this is what
would help us okay so we have this B
which is a fixed X helped me which is a
system of equations linear independent
right right because I mentioned two
properties one is the soundness I don't
want to write down equation that I
haven't seen or or inferred from the
input and the second is accuracy so I'm
gonna use soundness okay so so recall
that we have this random
one of my variables which correspond to
the computation path the vertex layer 0
1 up to M I want to look at Li will be
just the system of equations
okay I want to look at the following
progress measure Jedi which would be a
random Bible movie the dimension of the
span of L I intersection with the span
of LV we are basically the common
equations are shared by what I have
currently and what I'm aiming to to
reach okay so we are starting with that
zero equals zero
I'm going to begin we don't remember
anything in order to succeed we want
them to be K so basically we'll show
that the probability that said M equals
K how do we show that so in order to get
okay so let's see how does this a random
variable progresses so what can we do in
the branching program we can learn a new
equation we cannot learn more than one
equation because it just see one
equation we can forget stuff these are
the only two things that you can do and
we can basically everything is close to
the sponsor right if I know like three
questions also know like the there are
some so I can work with subspaces
so so but wait what I said the soundness
but if I remember only things that I've
seen you can infer you can see that Jedi
is always most previous values that it
got plus one not there more than one
question in the state basically we would
want to show that like the event that it
actually grows is happens with very
small probability so let's see what this
is the case
Oh
would say that the probability that said
I bigger than that I'm in school I want
to condition on everything that happens
in the first like ministery first one
steps
so I want to sort of like showy no
matter what I did in the first I minus
one steps so let's say that I fix the
history so I already got to a party like
a fixed X and I fixed the history like a
1 up to AI minus 1 so it means that I
reached to a particular vertex in the I
minus 1 layer now ask whether or not in
the next layer I learned a new equation
that is somehow in this intersection
that is in LV s in order for this to
happen I must have that suppose I die to
be graduated greater than that I minus 1
must have that
equations that I see in the ISTEP should
be in the span behind this one or sorry
alignments 1 Union L V this is a small
check ok except two lines to show that
the only ways that you you could
increase the dimension is if this
equation set on the span of what you
learnt so far and what you are trying to
get to how does it help us where we
assume that everything gets called I
mention at most case or the number of
equations is at most K in each thing so
this means that the dimension of this
guy is at most K so this is a set of
size 2 to the 2k at most a I will
selected uniform at random condition on
everything that happened up to this
stage this happens with probability this
number of possibilities divided by 2
now how do we prove this thing so in
order to get to K we need to have at
least K indices where we increase the
value of the diabetes that said M equals
a K this is most like a union bond over
like a kata also and I wanted that in
step i-1 I increase there is a step by
to increasing said I want said I J for
all J is greater than said I J now I can
write this as like the probability of
the first event up n times the
probability the second event event
commission on the first event happen so
on so forth on each time I'm having like
something like this condition on some
history so this would be at most to the
N raised to the power K
and how many tuples do I have m to the K
at most I have the bound that I want
okay this finishes the proof yeah no one
wanted to recall this intuition that we
had why is it hard to learn spout
parakeet because we in some point in the
computation missing this model we must
learn let's say n over five equations in
order to store them it requires us
something like N squared memory it's
only gonna be no it will be sort of by
saying that you know it's not like you
can say I want to learn this set of n
over five linear equations because then
you would find them in your stream of
example with very very small probability
so if you're not sort of like wait for
the right equation to arrive hey okay so
I think this this is a good a good place
to go to the to the second part which is
about results on general learning
problems so
besides again
so it seems that everything that we did
so far was very tailored towards
priority learning right we talked about
Fourier coefficient subspaces in our
equations it's not clear how to
generalize this to two other problems so
one way is you can do reductions as we
did with sparse case and DNS but this is
limited so we want a more general
framework and a more general proof and
so they call you post this question can
you generalize the proof for problem not
involving poverty and then this design
of wall of frauds and Moskowitz and
Moskowitz shows that indeed you can so
you get a new and general proof
techniques that work for a wider variety
of learning problems we will focus on
Roz's proof technique but there are
similarities between them it's a special
case you get a new proof which looks
that looks different for the party
learning case so you can show in this
new new proof technique lower bounds
that the memory is at least quadratic or
that this time is at least the number of
samples at least exponential
surprisingly these results did not
achieve the lower bounds that we knew in
sparse parities you know they were after
this paper but we managed to handle this
issue and to to generalize them even
further in a work with su mega and run
and independently of us all Cheyenne and
and Jung showed exactly the same result
and and these results actually unify all
all the results you can get parity
learning sparse party learning and more
and we will see some new applications
using this proof technique
okay so how do we even address this as a
question so I want to to view the
learning problem now as a matrix so I
will ever matrix the rows would be just
a finite set a the columns will be a
finite set X Y who is the row correspond
all possible samples that I could see
and the columns would correspond to all
possible functions that I'm trying to
learn okay so this is a huge matrix if I
think of parity learning it's a 2 by n
by 2 by n matrix its entry small a small
X I just put the value of the function X
on the input a the matrix now what is
the learning problem associated with
your matrix you pick a column uniform at
random and then you pick rows you start
picking rows uniform Metron random a 1 a
2 so on so forth and you give me the
value of the index of the row and the
value of the entry in the matrix okay so
so the rare learner gets to see this
sequence of a1 b1 a2 b2 life will be
free and if eventually needs to learn X
okay so let's see it as an example what
will be the matrix associated with the
parity learning
so this is a well-known matrix that
seems right so it's the atom out matrix
right so thank you
ex hey I said ex think of it as a
function it's like before we had X and
then here we have the inner product of a
and X but we are choosing now to go to
the plus minus 1 of tation so basically
we'll take minus 1/2
okay so this is the high demand matrix
and we know we love and love this matrix
we know a lot about this matrix we know
that that is an extractor with
reasonably good parameters and we will
use this property and this this matrix
is analyzing a lot of computational
models so I want to state the result
with su mega and run this is a result in
the language of extractors so we show
the business metrics for has some
extract or property specific saying what
the property is so the property is that
any big enough sub matrix is unbiased
okay so if you take this to the
mindscape fraction of the rows it means
to the myself fraction of the columns
then here the number of ones would be
very similar to the number of minus ones
only is the difference between them is a
fraction of this size would be at most
two to the minus R say that you have
this then you can prove lower bounds on
the memory which is K times L or on the
number of sample which is exponential in
our particular think of the inner like
the helmet matrix we know that you can
pick K Ln R to be linear in n many like
n over 4 or something
then you get quadratic memory or
exponential and also for the sparse
particular case we can sort of express
it in this language and I said
independently this result was proved by
by in this work the language is very
different but you can actually translate
between them and see that there are a
lot of similarities between the result
and the proof is very
so let's mention a few application of
this new
so first we have the previous
application we can learn parties and
weekly learns possibilities with which
actually was not done in the some of
these previous works we know we can
prove lower and I want to mention these
two new application so let's focus on
the last on this fourth one learning low
degree polynomials so so we talked about
party learning which is like learning a
linear function what if we generalize it
to degree to function degree this is the
learner tries to learn a polynomial or
multi linear polymer of the great most D
over at let's say f2 and he gets to see
run random points I guess to see random
X's and the value of of the polynomial
on it
so random ace because the sample so you
know the sample space so it gets to see
random s and P of a so in claims of any
learner for this model requires either a
memory enter the D plus 1 or 2 the n
number of samples basically you can also
do it by the outcome racer so basically
you can just store enter the D equations
and sort of like figure out what is the
right for you know you can also do it
efficiently with n to the D plus 1
memory if you want a little bit less
than that you need exponential number of
what is this for a learning problem very
similar to this one but there is a
difference so I have a vector X of
length M and I get to see a random
polynomial of degree D and the value of
this phenomenon X and I get to see a lot
of them a lot of different polynomials
so it's also a generalization of
learning sparse parities if you think
about it what's the relation between
these two things
yes so it's a transpose of the matrix
exactly and as you as you recall our
bound was based on the fact that the
matrix is an extractor if a matrix is an
extractor also the transpose is an exit
row so that's why does in our technique
is the raw ones that we get are the same
for any learning program and the
transpose of the learning problem and I
think it's sometimes like have a very
useful thing to think of like the
transpose like thinking of the inputs is
a function of the [ __ ] exactly right so
actually before this proof we couldn't
prove the crypto result we couldn't
prove that if you have this parity case
which is the transpose of the sparse
parity case
so in this particles what do we know we
know that X is sparse and is a random so
what if X was random and AIDS were
sparse but this is like learning from
the sparse equations right and we could
not prove it in the previous framework
but now since we have this
characterization we can prove that even
in this formal you can also get it for
the transport and hence for we get the
result in the crypto so as I mentioned
before we get a scheme that you need to
spend something like L time steps per
for encoding one bit and it is secure
against learner or attacker that has
less
and thanks el memories is the fact that
learning problem is hard and flies the
waitresses on extractor excellent
question I'm not sure if probably not
literally but maybe that there is a sub
matrix which is an expert but I'm also
not sure about that so yeah so this is
one of the oven questions that I want to
mention so easy actually characterized
that the problem eyespace hardness is a
function so I'm not sure okay how can we
show that what is the most useful
techniques in order to show that
something is an extractor this is
actually I will put all our all our
applications are proved in this way so
this is a well known and was previously
studied in order to show that something
is the instructor it's enough to show
that like the columns are nearly
orthogonal to one another so we have
this notion of epsilon Delta almost
orthogonal we want every column
to be almost orthogonal to it to all but
dealt a fraction of the other columns
okay so for every column at most Delta
fraction of the other columns of inner
product at most Epsilon with with this
column this basically this notion we can
show it for a lot of great polynomials
and sparse parity is and so on and so
forth
that's how we get the result and the
result is this wind if you have a matrix
which has this epsilon delta almost
orthogonal columns the learning requires
either the 1 over epsilon lo 1 over
Delta memory deeds or Polly 1 over
Epsilon number of samples okay and
basically for let's say for party line
you can prove it with epsilon Delta
which are exponentially small
we use the result of love that Ben
Eliezer and odd the basically tells you
that like like yeah correlation bonds on
the components so basing it translate
directly to this notion efficient later
yeah so you can ask yourself this
question it's a very interesting
question on its own and I think Polly
tile showed it also for the weak forms
over any field
okay so again the mother will be the
same as before the branching program
although the many differences that we
would not have this conversion we are
not simulating anything we will just
prove it in this model so again any
vertex V needs to come up with an
emphasis what is the value of X and we
want to show it it doesn't succeed with
probability we can also show here that
week learning is is also impossible and
yeah which is sort of stun and
straightforward from our proof
okay so again we look at this
distribution of X conditioned on V and
again we will do this Union but we will
look at a particular vertex V we will
call a significant vertex how do we
define significant vertex previously we
talked about vertices that remember K
equations now we don't have equations
anymore so we need to somehow do it only
with respect to this distribution so
what we want is we want the norm the l2
norm of this distribution to be big okay
so the l2 norm of the uniform
distribution is exponentially Continent
going to be 2l bigger than that
intuitively what does it capture it
captures that we know like L bits of
information on X but in the l2 norm not
in the entropy l2 is easier to work with
in this case and again what we will show
we will just for each particular vertex
probability of reaching to these
specific vertex is exponentially small
in K times L or N squared if you think
and again if you want to learn we must
reach a significant vertex because if we
haven't reach a significant vertex so
basically our distribution is sort of
spread around on so many X's that I
cannot tell which one is the right one
so I will fail so I must in order to
succeed I must reach the significant
work with my intuitive claim
okay and there is some complication so
you have to really show it on the
computational path we need to somehow
change it so so in the party learning
case we already always have this
condition that we can learn at most one
equation the general learning problems
maybe we see something very rare that
gives us a lot of information on X so
this is a little bit tricky but we can
somehow say that this doesn't happen it
happened the first multiple billion we
take like this is an event that is
global it's not with respect to a
particular vertex weights on the
computational part so we show that
basically you can assume that nothing
artifical is happening you can sort of
forget about that so what we want to
show is we want to show this thing
basically is the proof sort of will go
along at the proof of the event
branching programs we will have some
promise measure that we start small grow
slowly and that in order to get V it
should be big in the end what is this
Provost measure
so again recall that we have the vertex
player I VI we can look at the
distribution of X conditioned on this
vertex the distribution of explanation
like the specific vertex that we are
looking at currently the significant
vertex that we are trying to reach to
the measuring is the inner product we
take the inner product needs to
I want you to think this is really
capturing in in the oven cases this
intersection of the linear equations in
some sense it captures how much these
things are close together actually it's
it's literally the same if if these were
only offering subspaces since this would
somehow measure the size of the
intersection of the inner equations this
is a really the same as before the
weight thing is that we raise it to the
power K and the way the reason that we
do it is it otherwise will get only
linear bounds on the memory this way we
get quadratic writing weird but the
highest power starts at this measure
progress we'd not explode we be the
highest powers of it this behaves well
and K turns out to be the answer okay so
let's show these free bullets so
what is the value of this province
partition in the beginning what what do
we have in the beginning the beginning
know nothing about X so this is really
the uniform distribution the inner
product of any distribution actually
informed estimation is exponentially
smaller man simply minus an exactly so
we get here second step is the
complicated step we need to show that Zi
grows slowly this is similar to how to
what we did in the oven case where we
show that it's hard to learn a new
equation because we needed to learn
specific equation and here also we need
to come closer to a specific
distribution these were the hard part is
the third birth is all is all is simple
right so let's say that what is this
progress measure on the last layer that
is the probability of reaching this
vertex V times how much it contributes
to this expectation right so here we
have let's say ya replace V M with V
this is really the inner product of P X
conditioned on V with itself we know
that V is significant so we know that
this inner product is at least 2 to the
L times to the max can we raise it so it
took my son and we raise it to the power
K this is what we get third bullet main
difficulty is showing this to the second
bullet but at least and this is
something that I realize just preparing
for this tablet first like the same
structure as the affine branching
programs
and you can view it as actually the
promise function is not so far off of
what you have in there this is what I'm
not splitting vertices so it's like yeah
it's like terrorizing the easy part of
the actually this proof is shorter
okay so I want to finish with some open
problems
okay so somewhere already mentioned so
we I was already asking whether or not
we get the optimal trade-off for DNS the
decision trees and hunters so we got a
superlinear bond in the memory but that
one is quadratic so it's not clear
what's the right answer here it's not
even clear what are the limits of the
extractor based methods for this program
problems in particularly you can also
surf what is the basic cycles that you
can build where each row sorry each
column is let's say a decision tree or a
DNF then you build extractors if good
parameters if see if so then you prove
the new slow ones what Madhu is asking
is whether or not like there's anything
on leaf okay so we said if it's an
extractor you cannot learn if it's not
an extract of can you learn so maybe
there is a sub matrix which is an
extract also you cannot learn this sub
matrix so maybe let's say that every sub
matrix is not an extractor can you learn
I'm not sure and more generally you can
ask it to characterize combinatorially
when is efficient learning it can be
done with small space based on
properties of this matrix
very interesting government question is
to generalize our techniques to the real
value domain so we can generalize it
actually to any finite domain you can
generalize it to a finite output so you
don't need an attorney to to think about
within just one bit so we can look at
things that work maybe over big finite
fields or stuff like that but we don't
know how to do it for the reals
maybe we don't know how to this Union
bond right so another interesting
question is to generalize it for a model
where that looks at stream more than
once so in streaming it's very standard
model - too many duque passes on the
stream our lower bounds do not hold for
that one thing that we use is this the
fact is that the next sample is always
fresh randomness if we are looking at it
again and again so maybe remember some
of the samples and then behave
differently so we have some working
progress that we are able to get
something for two paths but currently
not 4k pass and what we get is even then
it's not tight even for the poverty line
okay so there is still a lot of work to
be done here
let me just finish with one problems
that I want to emphasize this is related
to neural networks which is a very hot
topic now I heard this talk of a
Sascha left Schwarz and he he basically
pointed out that there is a difference
between expressiveness and learnability
neural networks any process
he explained about our particular
experiment you take in your network
let's say depth to neural network and
you generate from it examples so you
show your sample random inputs and fit
into the network and take the output so
now you have a stream of examples now
you fill it to the same neural network
with the same architecture so it can
obviously like in terms of expressive
expressiveness it could express it
accurately with error 0 but it is a new
person you are the learner does not know
the weights so it knows the architecture
it doesn't know the weight you need to
learn the weapon is doing stochastic
gradient descent and he is not able to
learn the weights and he is not even
able to predict the outcome because
there was error is pretty big like in
most setting of parameters I wonder
whether or not this could be explained
by the fact that the learner is a small
amount of memory so if you think of a
stochastic gradient descent basically
the learner only stores his current
guests for the weights so it's like
linear in the description of the the
neural network
perhaps we can show that it's impossible
to learn in the linear space
this is something that the working
progress that we still cannot do it if
you have some ideas I can be happy
I guess I'll finish with that
[Applause]
yeah you think the transpose the lowborn
who carries from weight expected to the
transfer do you think I did great
question so yeah I think it would be
nice to show that like like if you can
do it for this learning problem you can
also do it from the transpose currently
we only know that the proof technique
worked for the transpose and this is
simple to see but we don't necessarily
know how to translate like an algorithm
for want to an item to another would be
very interesting to understand very
people like to look at this like a busy
day okay so there is something called
statistical query dimension which is
very similar to this or talk like
epsilon-delta orthogonal vectors so we
can also write it in this language so
basically it tells you that you have
like m functions that are a correlation
1 over m so there's only like one
parameter so we take two pounders
absolutely
and what the different distributions for
example if the concept comes from a
non-uniform distribution or the great
question so in this work with su mega
and run
we actually generalize it to arbitrary
distribution the condition is a little
bit more complicated and even the
distribution can be penned on the
function so you can have even a non
product distribution of the symmetric so
for each column you would have a
different distribution some of the
results still hold
it's open or you're welcome into which
the main so for any finite
[Music]
it seems it seems hard to write I mean
particularly like the samples could be
without any knowledge like even and then
it will be written something okay so a
result hold for weak learning so we will
show that you cannot even output and
prophesies that even slightly agrees
with your function so I guess if it also
works
right
[Applause]